[Music]
hello there guys we have a new look and
new information regarding spider-man no
way home so first off i'll show you guys
some new images that have been released
from the film so in the first picture
it's a shot of spider-man and mj and it
looks to be a continuation of um a
sequence from the trailer where they're
trying to detain spider-man and you have
the helicopter overlooking him so
basically spider-man and mj are on the
run and ultimately it does seem like
spider-man is taken under arrest as he
is interrogated later in the first
trailer anyway on to the second image we
have a picture of doctor octopus and
he's looking fantastic the d agent
technology the views on him here is is
really good marvel has always excelled
in the cgi for de-agent what's really
interesting is if you look at his
tentacles here it actually looks
different compared to how they usually
look
it's actually resembling iron man colors
with the red and gold here i'm not
really sure why this is but i guess
we'll just have to wait and see this
shot isn't too interesting so won't
spend too much time on it but it seems
to just be a behind-the-scenes shot of
doctor strange same as the next shot
here this is clearly a behind the scenes
feature of um peter parker tom holland
spider-man however the next shot here is
the money shot spider-man is not having
a good time here doctor octopus has a
good hold on him here he is definitely
not going to escape this and this may
remind you of a similar shot from
spider-man 2 to sam rammy films anyway i
wonder in this scene will the iron
spider suit be destroyed and will he get
a new suit so i'm thinking the reason he
gets a new suit is because it's
destroyed and it looks like in this
scene you know it looks like some damage
could be done so i'm wondering if that
will happen there anyway that's about it
for all of the new images that we have
released so far however got some new
information regarding spider-man no way
home so apparently the budget of
spider-man no way home will be a bigger
budget than any spider-man movie since
spider-man 3 and apparently be the most
shocking emotional and a spider-man
centric film so huge stuff like this is
just making me more and more excited
apparently nowhere home also has more
vfx shots and action scenes than any
other spider-man film so it sounds like
a lot is just going to go down and this
is also backed up by the director
because the director called it
spider-man endgame actually i have a
quote here from the empire issue
magazine saying spider-man no way home
isn't just a sequel it's a massive meta
multiverse outing in which peter parker
finds himself fighting iconic villains
from past lives as its creators tell us
this is nothing less than spider-man
endgame i'm not sure if you guys picked
up on that but it says you'll be
fighting iconic villains from past lives
now we know tom holland spider-man
hasn't had any past lives so is this
blatantly referring to the previous
spider-man being andrew garfield and
toby maguire what do you guys think let
me know in the comments section below
and also what do you think of this new
images release and when do you think
we'll get a trailer i think we'll get it
pretty soon so stay tuned for that guys
and make sure to like the video and
subscribe to show your support thanks
for watching
you